[Music]
hey it's me red you know the guy
everybody hated who kind of saved the
whole island anyway war with Leonard in
the pigs what are you gonna do I'm a
foodie still going on those what and Bob
and Chuck are doing whatever they do I
eat dirt and me well I still have some
anger issues but I'm finding healthier
ways to deal with it Fred I know we've
had our differences but we've discovered
that there's a third island maybe one
good reason why I should believe you now
show you the proof will do this is a
hundred times just don't think you're
gonna be compatible with the team oh wow
it's such a pleasure to meet not you but
you I like her we gotta get to the
island is what my assistant was going to
say
[Music]
this is the amazing team I've been
working around the clock for well that's
disappointing
step one we're gonna break in and
deactivate the weapon we look amazing we
gotta get that key card hello fellow
Eagle God how he's doing a voice yeah
I'm just gonna hide eggs but not
sometimes um the Easter Bunny comes and
keep putting my Gooch bunny hill comes
Easter Bunny come right now to
everyone's house and hides every egg and
then she does it again no looks like a
girl there looks like a boy good boy boy
boy boy boy hi
[Music]
it's made red welcome back to bird
island not much has changed I'm of
course still a hero and this war with
Leonard in the pigs has no end in sight
the easy stupid Bezos I guess birds and
pigs will always be enemies but we've
discovered that there's a third island
in their bodies you destroy us all
here's this eerie part we need to put
aside our differences and work together
are you freaking kidding me
each of you has been selected because
you're the best in your field then we
can find we got to be prepared for
anything is what my assistant was going
to say this is the amazing team I've
been working around the clock
well that's disappointing what's going
on down here yeah I'm just gonna there
aren't any good mother Day songs I think
we shouldn't that one okay Mother's Day
Mother's Day for Mother's Day
we go to brunch
[Music]
nope I'm not gonna just go out bridge no
it's mom I love you mommy
[Music]
there goes my toothpaste I am tired of
this I'm living on this frozen still
infested Allen
[Music]
we're gonna need a bigger slingshot
[Music]
[Music]